Speaker 1: All right.
I have something amazing for you guys.
Within just a couple of weeks of the leaked
news that the Supreme Court will soon be overturning
Roe v Wade, 2022 House of Representatives
polling has completely reversed, and in a
new NPR PBS Marist National poll, Democrats
are now plus five over Republicans looking
at the November congressional elections.
Now, we're not going to go crazy and get ahead
of ourselves.
I'm not going to start ripping apart my microphone
and burning it and celebrating anything.
Not that I would do that.
Anyway, we're going to look through this piece
by piece.
And in order to do that, we have to first
start with what would we expect in such a
midterm?
Typically in a midterm, the party that is
not in the White House does well right now.
Democrats are in the White House.
Joe Biden took the White House from Trump
in 2020.
And so we would expect Republicans to do really
well in the midterms.
Now, let's look at some previous examples.
In 2018, after Donald Trump took power in
2016, Democrats were plus seven in polling
going into the midterms, and they ended up
plus eight in an aggregate of congressional
races.
Okay, Trump wins next midterm.
Democrats +78.
In the 2014 midterms.
After Barack Obama won reelection, Republicans
were plus two, and they ended up winning by
almost plus six.
Obama reelection.
Republicans win 2010.
Barack Obama had just won in 2008 over John
McCain taking the White House from Republicans
previously held by George W Bush.
Obama wins 2008 2010.
Republicans were plus nine in the midterms,
ended up plus seven in those midterms.
Disastrous midterms for Democrats.
Okay.
So normally these first midterms, in particular,
the first ones.
But even after a Democratic reelection, you
expect to see Republicans do well.
We now have a stunning new poll.
These numbers, you really have to see them
to believe them.
47% of registered voters now say they will
support the Democrat on the ballot in this
year's congressional midterm, while 42% say
they will back the Republican.
That is plus five for Democrats in advance
of these midterms.
Now, we want to be thorough.
We don't look at just one poll.
We look at an average of recent polls.
And if you look at the Real Clear Politics
average of recent polls, you still have Republicans
plus two looking at the generic congressional
vote.
Now, that is dramatically lower than it has
been in any recent first midterm after the
party controlling the White House changes
power and it is declining.
Whereas Republicans were polling about an
average of 48% in February and about 47% in
mid-March, and they peaked at 47% again in
mid-May.
Now Republicans are down from where they were.
Could Republicans still will win?
Of course.
It's still the most likely scenario.
This is just one poll, but we are now seeing
multiple polls in an economist YouGov poll.
Democrats are leading a congressional vote
generic in a Politico morning consult poll.
Democrats are leading.
And yes, in that recent NPR PBS Marist poll
I just mentioned, Democrats are now plus five.
What this means is that the midterm might
not be over the impact of the Roe v Wade news,
especially if.
And when it becomes official, when the Supreme
Court finally announces its ruling, it could
really give Democrats a boost.
And what it means at the individual level
is every one of us must vote.
If you've ever voted before, you should vote.
If you've ever thought about voting, you should
vote.
If you've never voted, you should vote.
If you weren't old enough to vote in 2020,
but now you're old enough to vote legally,
of course you should vote.
If you've ever heard of voting, like if that's
a concept you've ever heard about, you should
vote because it doesn't have to be the disaster
that it was shaping up to be.
It seems as though the forthcoming Roe v Wade
decision is absolutely hurting Republicans.
One other interesting note from that poll,
which I think just should be mentioned, is
on the question of overturning Roe v Wade.
64% of Americans do not believe Roe v Wade
should be overturned, basically by a 2 to
1 margin, two thirds, one third.
Americans do not want the Supreme Court to
overturn Roe v Wade.
So if and when that happens, it could be exactly
the boost on which Democrats might be able
to ride to.
Could it be victory in November?
Maybe.
But could it be a much, much smaller loss
than what it was looking like three months
ago?
That very much could be.
And as I've said before, Joe Biden hasn't
done that much to help Democrats in November.
And we'll take all the help we can get to
get these Republicans or keep these wacky
Republicans out of power if they want to hurt
themselves by virtue of their own Supreme
Court picks, making a very unpopular decision
when it comes to Roe v Wade.
I'll take the help from anybody.
We can get it.
Anybody we can get it from.
I guess I should say let me know your thoughts.
Let me know what you make of this new polling.
And remember that we are now just one week
away, Monday, Memorial Day.
We will be doing a one day membership special.
All you need to do to be notified is get on
my mailing list at David Pakman dot com and
then on Memorial Day you'll get an email telling
you exactly how to avail yourself of this
extraordinary membership discount if you want
to join today.
You can do so at join Packman dot com.
We'll take a quick break
and
be back right after this